I didn't make fun of them yeah so what
did he displeased you
what did he just make them and he just
said that he doesn't want to go on as
about I said why Adi okay buddy do dogs
good sir we do
he's indeed Moody so I'm awakened one of
my three Medicare supporting sisters
hope you have to do well welcome to our
first dated both of Oscar chef
we're here with chef a 2-mile Haddad may
Allah bless him our first question I'm
gonna get straight into inshallah a
sister as message then saying that she
has two husbands how does this happen
because a lot of our thinking is this
even possible
so how does this happen can you explain
across yeah Fidel Jean McConville open
up a salon I love Selena actually I'm
really very happy that you brought to
this issue because it is a huge problem
vola it is a big problem I receive maybe
on a daily basis questions related to
this assistance having to her my sister
is confused who is the right husband for
her imagine with m-file I had a question
one
okay a call from a sister who said that
she had three husband and she was
cohabiting sleeping with three husbands
and not one moment but at the similar
period of time and each one of them was
claiming that he is jealous husband for
us he is the authentic husband for her
okay so does a bit different to the one
we have now yet no it is the same but it
can happen in different ways okay one of
them the most common one the most common
one how it happened is that many sisters
who are married by the law by the civil
court or by the Civil Registry they get
and they have of course an Islamic
marriage they get divorced by the civil
law they think that okay that divorce is
equal to an Islamic divorce so they
don't seek for an Islamic divorce they
just stop after that civil divorce okay
and then after a while they get married
islamically and then after some time
they realize that the civil divorce is
not an Islamic divorce is not an equal
is not equal to the Islamic divorce my
dear brothers and sisters I always
mentioned it it is a huge program in
fact today subhanAllah islam channel i
receive that question okay and before
going to islam channel on the satellite
i receive the question this is a huge
problem as i said i receive it on a
daily basis almost on a daily basis and
there are certain situations that are
really grave and and really bad okay
now regarding the civil divorce and the
islamic divorce the civil marriage and
the civil divorce is a system is a
complete system by itself
it has nothing to do with the Islamic
marriage under Islamic devote to
different systems in order to imagine
this yes imagine there is a lady who is
married by the for example British law
yes and she is married again by the
Indian look because if she is divorced
by the Indian law she needs a procedure
for her divorce to be valid here because
there is a civil divorce in India and
initiative divorce in the UK you see
there are two different sister yes one
one cannot replace the other and even
the civil divorce the Islamic so the
decision divorce the civil marriage they
don't recognize the Islamic one if you
drink Anika and in fact certificate to
the court
to the Civil Registry and you tell them
that I am married they say these people
means nothing it's the system who
receives the civil divorce take that if
the system is a system received an
Islamic divorce and takes that divorce
and goes to the civil registry to the
Civil Code and she says to them that I
have devolved they will look at it and
they will say this is not a divorce okay
yeah there was not recognize it as a
divorce
yes okay so we need to make sure our
sisters need to understand that the
civil marriage the civil divorce is
totally different from the Islamic
marriage the Islamic divorce if you
might use it if you are married by this
is a law it doesn't mean that you are
multiply that Islamic Shariah okay if
you aren't evolved by the civil law it
doesn't mean that you are divorce
Islamic and also it's an enum if you
have not civil marriage and no it's not
like only on screens you know why yes
yeah this is very like really like a
video so just just a quick background so
that is the reason why there is
wonderful reason one of the reasons why
so there are many other reasons okay
okay
one of the other reason is the fact that
this wrong impression okay that many
sisters have many many I dunno what is
the basis for that they believe that if
they are separated from their husband
for a period more than that the period
for more than three months then they are
automatically divorced yeah I had a case
of a sister
yeah she's matured system 42 um she said
20 years ago she was money to Amma and
then she left him okay she became
pregnant and she had the chance she left
that man with no Islamic divorce then
she got married to another man
she just doesn't match she stayed for a
period of one year or so she saw that
she is devoted from the other man she
was not devote and then she got married
to the third man and she had children
person from every single month and that
sister she was shocked to know that she
was not islamically divorced from the
first man okay not because she was
divorced from by this appeal oh no no
she was I don't think that she was
married by this below
so this impression that if you are
separated from your husband for a period
of time it means that you are
automatically divorce islamically is
completely wrong okay
just to sum up quickly and what is the
correct way to do it boba divorce it can
I do she takes do they need witnesses
maybe over the phone can you have two
definite in person can you quickly
summarize what the correct way for
Nevada was okay see before that for our
brothers and sisters to the ending is an
ending and Islamic marriage can be in
one of creasing divorce color yeah
divorce is initiated by the husband
colin is a request by the way but it has
to be approved by the husband first is
when the husband the wife is attacked
the husband refuses to divorce her and
then she will go to a proper Islamic
body to annul or dissolve the manifold
now let us go to the first one which is
the divorce
advocate the divorce is the decision of
the husband is the one who is divorcing
his wife
it can happen by text by word about by
email by any kind of hope you don't need
witnesses as far as the husband is
making it clear that he is divorcing his
wife yes
clinically then that is a valid Islamic
divorce now sometimes there might be
issues of anger yes this is of this is a
separate issue and Imam with
knowledgeable about these things he is
the one who should just on these things
not the husband not the one you guys can
if you call any queries that you want to
ask us to after share email as I asked
the chef at hotmail.com with your
questions and with initial put it would
share and have you answer
[Music]